clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic
merci à toi
[Musique]
talleyrand ça va ouais mais on travaille
aujourd'hui parce que c'est noël quand
même
ouais je fais tu as raison je sais mais
justement tous nos amis là qui comptent
sur nous on va les laisser tout seul
dans l'embarras la plaine danger pendant
les fêtes
on va pas les laisser comme ça c'est
noël quand même tu as raison bah je sais
que tu avais un quart d'heure te vois
rien n'a pas pour longtemps de toute
façon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je voulais juste vous
souhaiter de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
voilà j'adore délirer à ça je peux vous
dire qu'on va se marrer au réveillon
alors avant de vous présenter mes
meilleurs voeux je voulais vous proposer
deux petites choses une pour prendre
soin de vous et une pour prendre soin
des autres
d'abord pour ce qui est de prendre soin
de vous je vais vous donner trois petits
conseils pour vous mettre bien tout en
continuant à vous portez bien duvet de
l'eau avant les fêtes pendant les fêtes
vous souvenez un verre d'alcool un verre
d'eau et après les fêtes tout le temps
en fait
buvez régulièrement en quantité
suffisante c'est bon pour votre cerveau
pour votre coeur pour votre foi c'est
bon pour tout duvet de l'eau évidemment
et je vous rappelle que le coût de
soigner le mal par le mal
un lendemain de fête c'est une mauvaise
idée et évidemment mollo sur l'alcool
en règle générale même pendant les fêtes
vous savez ça aussi bien que moi même si
c'est bon mangez intelligent genre avant
le repas de noël et le lendemain bas
dont j'ai léger avant la soirée du
nouvel an si vous allez juste faire la
fête et page aura un dîner manger un
truc qui tient bien au corps un genre
une bonne plâtrée de pâte entre punk le
lendemain manger des trucs faciles à
digérer mais ne restez pas à jeun
l'estomac vide un lendemain de cuite
c'est une mauvaise idée
et puis en plus besoin de vous regarder
un petit peu si vous êtes barbouillé si
vous avez un petit peu du mal manger en
petites quantités mais régulièrement
dormait mais pas trop alors oui dormait
avant les fêtes pour être en forme
dormez après mais ne passait pas à votre
journée du lendemain à faire que ça il
faut mettre la machine en marche pour
éliminer ce que vous avez à éliminer et
le corps quand vous dormez y
fonctionnent au ralenti et quand ils
fonctionnent au ralenti l'éliminent pour
ralentit donc sortez vous balader au
moins un peu et après si vraiment c'est
votre truc vous pouvez revenir regarder
un film yes ou un plein mais aller faire
un petit tour quand même par contre
aller pas courir un marathon non plus
c'est bon c'est avec coeur tous ces
conseils et plein d'autres jeux les
détails dans ma vidéo sur la gueule de
bois donc
vous invite à retourner la voix est
aussi dans mon manuel de survie en
période de fêtes et pour un peu plus
tard il ya celle sur les bonnes
résolutions et comment les tenir et
aussi celle sur comment se remettre au
sport sans se faire du mal
je vous remets tout lé bien dans la
description mais surtout je voulais vous
donner un petit coup de main si vous
êtes dans l'embarras genre si vous êtes
à la bourre dans vos cadeaux de noël
et là j'avoue si vous n'êtes pas encore
fait vos courses de noël au moment où
vous regardez cette vidéo vous êtes
sacrément l'amour si vous n'avez pas
fait vos cadeaux et que vous n'avez pas
envie d'aller vous faire piétiner dans
une galerie marchande
j'ai un petit truc pour vous que vous
pouvez commander sur internet juste
avant de partir vous faire péter la
ruche au réveillon vous pouvez offrir
aux gens que vous aimez un truc dont on
manque toutes et tous et qu'on s'offre
pas assez à soi même
du temps du temps pour soi je veux dire
alors bien sûr vous pouvez offrir une
box pour aller manger au restaurant où
passer un week-end dans une yourte
vous pouvez aussi offrir une carte
cadeau avec des places de cinéma il ya
plein de trucs comme ça vous pouvez
trouver il n'y a pas de problème mais
moi ce que je vous propose c'est
d'offrir un moment pour qu'on prenne
soin de votre proche alors genre quoi
chercher un peu vous allez trouver plein
d'idées parmi les trucs que j'ai testé
il ya par exemple la cryothérapie
alors faut plus voir ça comme un
investissement à moyen terme parce que
sur le moment c'est spécial c'est pas
forcément la fête du slip là mon pénis
et une noix de cajou actuellement mais
après on se sent bien il ya aussi
l'isolation sensorielle la flottaison
on peut y aurait deux là pour le coup on
a l'expérience immédiate qui est cool et
l'effet relaxant qui dure un petit peu
après bon il ya plein d'autres trucs du
même genre si vous fouillez un petit peu
vous allez trouver ce qui convient pour
votre proche il ya les soins les
massages laisse pas tout ça il ya plein
de trucs mais vous pouvez aussi offrir
une séance de relaxation ou de
sophrologie chez les uns ou une
professionnelle va forcément un truc que
les gens prennent le temps spontanément
de faire c'est un réflexe
pourtant ça fait du bien et pour les
gens qui sont vraiment trop casanier
pour sortir de chez eux ou qui ont des
agendas de start up or il ya toujours la
possibilité d'offrir une appli
méditation de relaxation etc bref vous
avez l'idée offrez lui un moment pour
elle ou pour lui offrez lui du temps
parce que le temps en vrai c'est pas de
l'argent
ahmad prix alors bon si vous avez déjà
tout prévu que vous avez acheté tous vos
cadeaux
bah ça vous fera une idée pour une
prochaine fois où pourtant ton machin
qui était pas prévu mais finalement il
est invité à noël et on vous dit que
maintenant
et puis pourquoi pas pensé à vous faire
ce genre de cadeau à vous même un nul
mérité aussi mais surtout j'ai un autre
truc qui va là pour tout le monde on en
a déjà parlé ya pas longtemps pensé
aussi à celles et ceux que vous
connaissez pas forcément mais qu on
vraiment vraiment besoin d'un truc que
vous pouvez leur offrir sans que ça vous
coûte et sans que ça vous prive de rien
vous pouvez donner votre moelle osseuse
vous pouvez donner votre sperme ou
d'ovocyte je vous remets les liens vers
ces deux vidéos là dans la description
mais vous pouvez aussi donner votre sang
aux plaquettes votre plasma etc
voilà vous avez vu c'est pas si
difficile de se mettre bien se faire du
mal
c'est pas non plus compliqué de prendre
soin de soi et de prendre soin des
autres donc pas fait tout et avant de
filer je vous laisse avec un petit
cadeau vous souhaite un joyeux noël au
beau souhaiter joyeux noël on vous
souhaite un joyeux noël et bonne année
m
mettez vous bien elle surtout portez
vous bien
[Musique]